>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Good morning.
We know we are now back from the
summer holidays and we are ready
to dig in with the
important work that we do.
Judith Cannan had to come by
the office, I was off last week,
to make sure I had not forgotten
where I was, and what I was supposed
to be doing [laughter], and
she happened to see me looking
at the flier so at least she knew
I remembered there was a program
this morning.
This is another in the series
that Library Services sponsors,
LC's Digital Future and You, that
is coordinated by Judith Cannan
of the COIN Division, and
Angela Kinney of ALAWE,
who is on leave this week.
I am Beacher Wiggins,
Director of Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access for
the one person who may not know
who I am [laughter], and I'm going
to kick off this morning's session.
The title "BIBFRAME
On the Move" is trying
to capture the ever evolving
development of the Library
of Congress' initiative,
and foray into linked data.
It's a prime initiative.
We want to give you a sense of
what has happened, where we are,
and what we are expecting to
occur over the next few months,
and particularly into fiscal 2017.
So I'm going to give you
and our participants, today,
I should run those down, and
we'll just follow in order.
And we think saving questions
until the end is better,
but if you have burning questions
as each one of us finishes,
and you raise your
hand, we will stop
and answer those questions for you.
So in addition to me,
we will have Kirk Hess
from the Network Development
and MARC Standards Office,
and Paul Frank from COIN,
who will play off each other,
and give you a sense of the
BIBFRAME Editor, how that worked,
which is one of the
centerpieces in terms
of the tools used to
work with BIBFRAME.
Then we have Sally McCallum, who
is Chief of the Network Development
and MARC Standards Office, who
will tell us about the plans
for the next phase of our operation,
and I'll give you a very brief
background of where we are
and then move into Kirk
and Paul's taking over.
About this time last year I
guess it was, I had determined
that we needed to do a pilot.
Well I guess it was a little
bit beyond a year ago,
do a pilot to test what we had
been talking about, we the Library
of Congress, in terms of BIBFRAME.
And I was adamant that we move
forward, whether we were quite ready
or not, and we were, in some
respects, not quite ready
but we rose to the occasion.
So by late 2014 early 2015, we were
moving forward, because we wanted
to test the efficacy of
BIBFRAME, how we could use it
and what components of it
we could test going forward,
and in particular, the
ability of our staff
to be able to deal with that.
To that end, then, we identified
some 40 to 45 staff members,
both within the Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access area,
and in the Special Formats
areas, to help us carry it out.
And we got a mix of
cataloguists, technicians,
and we covered all format
types, languages and scripts.
Monographs, serials, cartographic
materials, music, notated,
sound recordings, two-dimensional
artwork, bringing in our colleagues
from Prints and Photographs.
We wanted the staff to process
whatever materials they normally
process, whatever crossed
their desks, and we wanted them
to do it using the BIBFRAME Editor.
But in addition, because the
Library of Congress must continue
to distribute its cataloguing
data in MARC format,
they also had to catalogue those
same items using the MARC format.
So obviously that was going to cut
into their time and
their production.
So production was never
a focus of the pilot.
We termed an idea, when
I talked to the classes
that were being instructed
in preparation,
and the COIN Division did say
training, that these spoke
with prior needs, one, because
we had some development work
that we were still doing, and we
wanted input and feedback from them,
and frankly because they were
doing something that was new,
and we weren't quite sure what
we were going to get out of that.
To be prepared, they attended
some 16 hours of training,
instruction that was
being offered by COIN.
And the pilot preparation on
the technical side then was done
by Network Development
and MARC Standards Office,
and that included being able to
create a BIBFRAME-like environment.
And that called on transforming
the existing MARC records,
some 18 million were targeted
into BIBFRAME description,
so that the participants would have
that environment to search against,
as if they were in a
production mode for BIBFRAME.
The outcome was commendable.
That did actually convert some
13.5 million records into work
and instance records,
so that the staff
who were participating would
be able to do the searching
and to get a feel for
what that would be like.
Sally may go into more
detail about that,
and how that might change
for the upcoming pilot.
The BIBFRAME Editor was developed
as the primary tool for the staff
to use, and we'll get
more information on that.
The staff used the authorities
as they were in LC.gov,
and had that as a basis for
the authority was created,
and how that was going to enact with
the work that they would perform.
Some-the last number I got was
like 2,000 BIBFRAME
descriptions that were created.
I'm sure that's more like 3,000
now, because one of the things
that we did, and what I haven't
said so far, is that the pilot ran
from October 1, 2015 through March
31, 2016, and during that period,
some 2,000 descriptions
were created.
At the end of the pilot, so
that staff would continue
to retain the skills
that they had developed,
I determined that they should
develop, devote one day per week
to continuing to grade
records in BIBFRAME.
I also should note that
the day it was created,
was done in the BIBFRAME 1.0
environment, and all those data
that were created will be discarded,
because this was all
in the test mode.
We will think differently
about the upcoming pilot,
and Sally may speak a bit more
to that in terms of the stability
of the data that will be created.
The next thing that
had-well, one of the things
that happened during this period
was the development of BIBFRAME 2.0,
and that is going to be the platform
and underpinning that will be used
for the pilot going forward,
and will be the basis of a lot
of the testing that will be
going on, not just in the Library
of Congress, but also as part
of our external partners,
that Sally may also touch on a bit.
The one thing I should mention
before turning over to Kirk
and Paul is that work flow didn't
change, because staff had to work
in both environments,
we just overlaid whatever staff
were doing in their regular work.
So we did not test the work flow,
and we have not done an analysis
of how BIBFRAME will
affect work flow.
And the other piece, we should say,
is that it also doesn't affect
the acquisitions side of it,
or the user access to the
data that are created.
All of those will be components
that we'll have to worry
about as we move forward.
So as you can see, there
is a lot to be done.
I think we've made great strides
in terms of what we want the pilot
to do to show that we could do
this, that we could develop a tool
that staff could use, that
staff could actually adapt to.
I think we did that.
The next challenge for
us is expanding this.
Do we use the same participants?
Do we expand the number
of participants?
How do we get that training done?
One of the things that I want is to
make sure we're developing a cadre
of experts that we can
expand and build on so
that as we roll this out.
And ultimately we'll have to
go beyond Library Services,
and beyond ABA, in terms
of what we want to do.
So with that very high
level synopsis, now-well,
are there any burning questions
for me before I turn it
over to Kirk and Paul?
Seeing none, then I
will ask Kirk and Paul
to proceed as they have determined.
>> Paul: Good morning everybody.
>> [Group response] Good morning.
>> Paul: Yeah, I'm not as young as
I look [laughter], but it's so funny
when Beacher made that
comment about, you know,
the beginning of the Fall
season, I still feel like the day
after Labor Day is the
first day of school,
so all those nerves
[laughter] and everything.
So here we are on the
first day of school.
But I'm Paul, this is Kirk.
I think of us maybe as Abbott
and Costello [laughter], or Sonny
and Cher-[laughter] but the
point is, pick your duo.
We work very closely as a duo,
and it was very interesting,
because we were facing
in different directions,
but we had to meet in the middle.
So my focus was on
cataloguers, right?
Reaching out to cataloguers.
Kirk's was finding that interim
between cataloguing and technology,
and facing out toward the
technology environment.
So it was a very productive duo.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that.
And because of that, I thought it
would be good, or it was suggested
and I agreed it would be a good
approach to have us both stand
up here and have us go back and
forth and talk about our roles
in the BIBFRAME Pilot from
last year, and into this year.
>> Kirk: Hopefully
we can both be heard
with the microphone in the middle.
We didn't think about the
microphone [laughter],
we're playing the duo,
one microphone.
Okay.
>> Paul: Alright, so this
dynamic duo didn't come
into play right away, right?
So in 2014, we were given a
BIBFRAME Editor to work with,
to play around with,
to experiment with.
We hadn't even thought
about a Pilot at LC.
We just-here is, here is a
product, let's test it out.
It was really very interesting.
I'm just using screenshots.
You can look down the
left-hand side,
and you see the different formats,
records print, bibliography, books,
dissertations, paintings.
Very broad.
On the right-hand side, you could
see one of the input screens
that you would use in the editor.
Really no different from what we did
in the pilot, but think about this.
You see no code, no cataloguing
code represented here.
I made the comment in the past that
this would be perfect for someone
who had, say, a very large
collection of sound recordings,
personal collections, they
wanted to describe them, right?
Describe your own personal library.
This would be a perfect
way to do it.
If you had LPs, you
could put the album name,
you could put the artist, you
could put the description, subject,
everything that you would need
to use for your own library.
And beyond that, this
could also work very well
in a public library environment.
A public library could make
great use of something like this.
But think about the Library of
Congress, and the work that we do,
and compare it against
what we have here.
So one other screenshot
that I wanted
to show you was-and I use
quotes here, "authority work."
This is how authority
work would have been done
in this prototype system.
It's certainly very user friendly.
If you're creating a
new authority record,
you put first name, last name.
I love that, you know, we're
not dealing with surnames,
or entry elements, all these
things that cataloguers deal with.
You simply enter in the name.
But the funny part to me was
the birth date, death date.
Now, the comment I made about, you
know, I'm not as young as I look,
when you have to go online, you're
making a profile on some site,
and you have to put
your date of birth.
Well, you don't usually just
enter in your date of birth,
they give you a drop-down
calendar, right?
And you go all the way back, and
I'm old enough to think I wonder
if my year is even on this
list that drops down, right?
[Laughter] Well, it usually is.
But what would you do if you
were born in the second century?
If you're setting up an authority
record for someone who lived
in the second century, you're going
to have to do a lot of clicking
to get to that calendar,
and then by that point,
what difference does it make that
the person was born on a Tuesday
or a Wednesday at that point?
I mean, it's just, I'm making fun of
this, but I don't want to underplay
that it certainly had a use.
It could not, maybe, be used
at the Library of Congress
for the type of work that we do.
On the other side of the
screen you see a new topic.
I mean, think LCSH if
you're a cataloguer.
If you wanted to propose a
new LCSH heading, you know,
there is a very elaborate way to
do that, and certain rules have
to be followed, instructions
have to be consulted.
So the editor that we had in 2014
was a start, but by 2015 we knew
that we were going to have a
pilot at the Library of Congress.
Beacher already gave you a very
good overview of what we did.
Our cataloguing code standard is
Resource Description and Access,
RDA, so we had to take this
editor and turn it into something
that cataloguers could describe
resources using RDA with,
and so that is where the
team came together, this duo,
and I'm going to let Kirk now talk
about all the things that needed
to be done to modify what you see
here and what we used in the pilot.
>> Kirk: So profile editor.
So when you-a few slides ago you
saw there was a list in the side
of Formats, things like book,
or electronic book,
those kinds of things.
So what are those?
Those are profiles.
So what's a profile?
Well it's basically just a template
of fields that are grouped together,
and in the original prototype,
it was hard coded in there.
There was no way to change it.
No way to add a new one, other
than coding it by hand in JSON,
which would be very difficult for
people who don't know anything
about JSON, or even
what that stands for.
So we contracted out to develop
this tool called the Profile Editor,
and this is what Paul and I used
to develop some of the profiles.
The first one we worked
on was monograph,
because that's always the bulk
of work in technical services.
So you can see here there's a
name, there's some elements,
see at the bottom there is
preferred title for the work,
and you notice it has
these RDA terms.
So one of the things we decided
to do was use RDA description,
and that's something Paul is
going to talk about later,
but basically the idea there is
basically so you know the rules,
and you can just enter it
in the field, for the rules,
other than trying to
remember an archaic number,
like MARC, the way that MARC works.
So another kind of challenge we had
was there are many lists of things,
as well as lookups for things.
So an example of a lookup is a name.
We talked about that.
Before, you know, you want to
find Tim Carlton is an example
that Paul always uses,
so which Tim Carlton?
Well, you know, the one with
this date, born on this date.
So you can look that up in
id.loc.gov, our linked data service.
But we want to make sure it's
actually enabled within the tool,
and so one of the things that was
enabled within this system was
that at the bottom of the screen,
you can barely see
there's something-values,
there's a URI there,
which is a lookup service.
So zooming in, so that's
actually the URL you can go
to in your browser, and it goes
to the linked data service,
and you can enter in a keyword
or a name, and it will look up,
and you can see names there.
Well, it works the
same in the editor,
and that's how it was keyed in.
One of the things Paul
wanted me to mention was
that when we originally did this,
all the lookups while we could
add them to the profiles,
they were hard-coated
into the editor
by the previous instance of this.
So if Paul came up with a new
list, he had to tell me about it.
I had to go in the code, I had to
write more code to add that list,
and in addition to we actually
had to load it into id.loc.gov,
so eventually we realized there were
many lists that were already in ID,
but we couldn't use them, because
you had to do this whole process.
So I figured one of the
things I added was the ability
that any generic list that's an ID
could be accessed through the tool.
So that was another
little challenge we had.
It ends up that there
are certain things
that are a little bit different,
depending on the results.
So in this case, you're
searching for a name-those had
to be a little bit more specific.
But if you're just looking up
a code, what's another one,
like format, format is one
thing that we had-[inaudible],
those things were just
you could put in there.
So let's see.
So I think Paul is going to
talk about now our Pilot.
>> Paul: Right.
So while Kirk was doing all this
work with the editor that you saw,
or hopefully saw on the slides,
we were gearing up for this Pilot.
Beacher said 40 to 45 cataloguers,
LC cataloguers, all RDA cataloguers
at the beginning, and we added on
some cataloguers who use DCRM(G),
a little bit later, to test
another code in BIBFRAME,
but in order to have the Pilot,
we wanted to at least give
participants some background
in what's going on in this
linked data, semantic web world,
that they're participating in.
They didn't need to have
exhaustive understanding of this,
but we thought it would
be very helpful for them
to have a basic understanding of
what their descriptions were going
to do once they got out there,
you know, got out to the web,
or got to another area of access.
So we started with a Module 1,
which we called Introduction
to Semantic Web and Linked Data.
When you have the slides,
you'll be able to hyperlink
from the header here, and go right
to this BIBFRAME training page,
which I encourage everyone
to go to it.
It's available externally
as well as internally.
There's some very helpful
information there, just if you want
to have a passing understanding, if
you want to increase your knowledge
that you have now, of what's going
on, this is a great place to start.
Module 2, talked about the BIBFRAME
tools that we would be using,
particularly the editor,
the controlled vocabularies
that we access through the linked
data service, things like that,
and then the third module was in the
actual use of the BIBFRAME editor.
So the next slide shows you where
we started and where we were
when the Pilot actually began
last June, June of 2015.
So the slide on the image on the
left shows that initial screenshot
that I showed you earlier on.
We've gone now to a much
more robust profile.
All of the profiles we were
using in the Pilot listed here,
all set up according
to RDA instruction.
So that's the important part here.
Now we've introduced a code
into a cataloguing code
into the BIBFRAME editor.
So when you look at the
BIBFRAME editor, you will see,
rather than simply formats listed,
and generic labels for information
that you want to input, RDA
vocabulary is explicitly presented,
so RDA work, RDA expression,
on the-in the editor itself.
The instructions in RDA were
hyperlinked, so if you're working
with a MARC record,
okay, let me step back,
you're doing MARC cataloguing
in RDA, what do you do?
Well, you look at the MARC tag, what
does this tag mean, you might need
to go to the MARC authority format,
MARC bibliographic
format, to figure that out.
Then you have to make a leap to how
does that MARC element map to RDA?
You're doing a lot of thinking
here, and a lot of work,
and the BIBFRAME editor,
you click on the link,
you go right into the RDA tool kit.
You can read the instruction,
so we've eliminated
that intermediate thinking step
that MARC brought into the picture.
Didn't do it intentionally,
it was just a matter of fact,
that's the way MARC was,
when we used RDA in MARC.
So I highlighted here RDA work, RDA
expression, subject of the work,
creator of the work, to give
you an idea of the RDA-ness
of the editor and the profiles here.
I will say one of the
biggest challenges
in the Pilot was reconciling
the differences in vocabularies
between BIBFRAME and RDA.
Whereas BIBFRAME vocabulary does not
have the concept of an expression,
RDA certainly does, and we had
to map in the best way possible
that we could come up with, a way to
reconcile that apparent difference
in vocabulary and the guiding
principle was that cataloguers
in the pilot should not have
to do anything differently
when applying RDA as a code.
Right? We could not introduce
any roadblocks there.
They had to be able to
do their work in RDA,
except do it in the BIBFRAME editor.
So one of the facts that we
kept stressing to participants,
even though we asked them to
take some semantic web training
and linked data training was
that once they input a
description using the editor,
they did not really need to be
too concerned about what came
out the other end, you know,
the Kirk side of the duo.
Through some interesting
turns of events,
it turned out that
we actually did look
at in the Pilot the participants,
we all looked at the output,
but I wanted Kirk to talk
a little bit about that,
because it's certainly something
that he knows much
more about than I do.
This is an example of a record,
of a resource that was
described in BIBFRAME.
>> Kirk: Okay, so just, I'll
breeze over this a little bit.
Basically there is an ID at the
top of one of these little groups,
and all of them say underscore,
colon, B node, a weird number thing.
Those are just saying that
that's part of a document.
You could have an externally
available URL, or URI,
they call it, that you can access.
Well, in this case, it's
not accessible externally,
it's actually within the document,
but we still want to keep it
as a group, so these are
all subjects, topics,
in this case, because
that's the type.
We use the BIBFRAME.
And you also notice here that if you
could actually see this very well,
it doesn't have RDA
stuff in here now.
Now, we just have BIBFRAME.
So the actual like
encoding format is separate
from the cataloguing process.
So you use the instructions
from RDA, and you get BIBFRAME.
We have two examples here, the
ones that are larger are ones
that we actually could, as I kind
of mentioned before with looking
up names, we could
also look up subjects.
So a subject was looked
up, it's NID, it has a URI,
so that URI is the authority,
and then we also have just-it's
not human readable, really,
I mean it's just a number.
So we also have some access
points, which is something
that BIBFRAME 1.0 used,
as well as a label.
But access points are kind of a-a
construct for an older system,
where you didn't actually have
a unique identifiable number
for something, so you kind of had
to identify it by a series of words.
So now we're kind of
moving away from that,
because we already have something
that is unique, which is the URI,
and then all you need is
a human readable label,
and that is something
that is consistent
with how other linked
data systems work.
The second example we ran into is
where using the rules for LCSH,
you can construct a heading that
may not actually be authorized,
essentially.
So at the bottom, these
ones that are short,
just have an authorized
access point, that's basically
where the cataloguer
just typed it in.
They looked it up, they typed it in
with all the little double dashes,
and everything that is in there,
it's not really validated.
Those all really should have URIs
attached to each one of those parts.
But in the Pilot, we never actually
figured out that particular method,
so that is one of the things
we're going to be working
as our next [inaudible],
so that's that.
Okay, so that's one lesson learned.
>> Paul: Yeah, so now I want to
talk about those very same topics
from the cataloguing point of
view, that maybe more of you
in the room might be
able to relate to.
So this is where the duo had
some-we had some disagreements here,
you know, it wasn't always rosy.
So we had certain constraints
in the Pilot,
and one of them Beacher mentioned,
that we were asking cataloguers
to do duplicative work, right?
You would do your description
in the Voyager ILS,
and then you would
do it in BIBFRAME.
Toward the end of the Pilot, we
reversed that order, you could start
in BIBFRAME, then go to the
ILS, but cataloguers needed
to do their work two times,
but I think it worked out well,
and I think we learned
a lot from that.
But what cataloguers do, and what
technology people think cataloguers
do are totally different [laughter].
So a cataloguer, or
actually, let's not be biased
against technology people, just
the average user, the public user,
so let's say you go to Google,
and you're looking for something.
Right? You're going to put in
generally a keyword search,
something is going to come up,
you're going to get results,
you go through, you
refine your search, maybe,
or maybe you find exactly what
you want in that first screen.
That's what a user does, and I think
that's what technology people think
cataloguers do.
But cataloguers are actually
looking for something
that they want to be sure exists.
We're searching to
find duplicate, right?
So we have to have a much
more targeted search.
Keyword searching is great,
but for cataloguing purposes,
that left anchored search
is even more important,
because we're looking for the
known, not for the unknown.
So, for example, I wanted
to use a resource that is
about to be actually has been
published, just this year,
it's called linked data
for cultural heritage.
I showed the MARC record, in fact,
Sally McCallum was
involved with this.
She has a chapter in this resource.
I hadn't read it yet, but I'm
looking forward to doing that.
But I want to just
talk about what we did
with the names and
the subjects here.
So we have editors, Ed Jones, and
Michelle Sakol [assumed spelling],
then we have a really nice array of
LCSH subjects assigned for the work.
So let's take the adjuncts,
I'll give Tim Carlton a break,
because I'm always using Tim, so I
thought I should get somebody else.
Let's talk about Ed
Jones, and let's talk
about that second-well the
first two subjects, linked data,
but more importantly, the second
one, linked data case studies,
with the form subdivision, and
talk about what BIBFRAME does
with those, with those things.
So here is the person lookup that
we would use in the BIBFRAME editor.
Kirk already told you,
this is searching
against the name authority
file, as it resides,
as linked data in id.loc.gov.
So a cataloguer at first, when
we were starting the Pilot,
this was totally relevant
ranked keyword searching.
That is not going to help
a cataloguer who wants
to see how many Ed Jones' there
are, and if the one he wants,
or she wants, is already
represented.
So now meeting of the minds, we
now have a left-anchored search
in id.loc.gov, you search in Jones,
and you get a great array
of possibilities here.
Now, one of the advantages
of doing your work
in the voyager ILS first is that you
would already have decided which one
of these Ed Jones' you needed,
because right now, in the editor,
you are not able to retrieve
the actual authority record
to analyze it.
You can only see the 1xx, the
heading, and you know, again,
technology people will go
why is that so important?
You just want the identifier,
that's all that matters,
and certainly that's true
in the linked data world,
it's all about identifiers,
but cataloguers still rely
on that text stream, right?
So we have to be able to see that.
So it searches very well in ID,
and it turns out that the Ed Jones
we want is the one who was born
in 1951, we could click on that.
But you might have noticed
that there is a second box
that says record authorized
access point if added to LCNAF,
but does not appear in id.loc.gov.
Well, why would that happen?
Because there is an overnight
distribution of authority data
from our Voyager in NACO node,
the voyager name authority file,
into id.loc.gov, if you were
cataloguing that resource today.
The Ed Jones that you needed
had not been established.
You would have to establish it
in Voyager using our
cataloguing client,
but the record would not distribute
to id.loc.gov until the next day.
So we have a way that
cataloguers could input the label,
the authorized access point that
they were creating to hold it
in the BIBFRAME database.
Now let's talk a little
bit about subjects, again,
from a cataloguing point
of view and not so much
from a linked data perspective,
although it certainly has
an impact on linked data.
That second one that
I highlighted here
at the top is linked
data with case studies.
Now if we searched subjects, again,
looking up against id.loc.gov,
we key in linked data,
we get a match.
It's right there.
Linked data.
There's nothing in the LCNAF
until somebody holds a conference,
a linked data conference, right?
So we're happy with what we
see, because we want a topic,
we want a topical heading
for this resource.
But you don't see case studies
there, so what's going on?
Why isn't it there?
For many years, LCSH has worked
on a very pragmatic principle
using free-floating subdivisions.
So certain topics fit
into categories,
and under those categories,
there can be certain subdivisions
that are appropriate
to those categories,
so you can pick an appropriate
subdivision from the list
that is appropriate to the heading.
And you don't need to
create an authority record.
This was not always
the case with LCSH,
at one time there was an
actual authority string created
for every LCSH heading.
Well, always dangerous to say
"every," but much more regularly.
But the free-floating practice,
fewer authorized heading subdivision
combinations were being created,
but it was an expedient decision
because it increased the time
of working through production.
I mean, things went faster
when you didn't have to set
up the authorized access point
for every heading subdivision
combination.
In fact, although we saw linked data
as an authorized heading in LCSH,
there is also a subdivision
record for case studies.
Those subdivisions have their
own authority records as well.
But what we had to do in the
Pilot was ask cataloguers
when applying a heading subdivision
combination that conformed
to free-floating practice
to explicitly put
in the heading subdivision
combination with the double dashes,
the traditional LCSH shorthand,
and then that in the BIBFRAME back
end would convert to what you saw
in an earlier slide
that Kirk talked about.
But now, I'm going to
put Kirk on the spot,
because what I never was quite
sure about was what happens
to this string in BIBFRAME?
So does the ID up here
represent that string?
>> Kirk: So, yes.
The ID would represent
that string basically,
but you kind of see a
little bit of a problem,
because back when I was
trying to explain this before,
it's a blank node, and so
it's not necessarily something
that is easy to find or reuse.
So one of the challenges
we have like in this case,
is this something we're
going to, you know,
we want to be able to
find again somehow?
You might have to save it.
We might have to change
this from blank node
to a different construction, where
it's like a...something local
to our system, but not
necessarily something you want
to say everyone should
use, it's just something
that we're using internally because
we thought it was a good idea.
Because otherwise you're going
to have to do this, you know,
you're doing it one
time is one thing,
but what if you're
doing it 100 times?
You know, what if there was 100
case studies you had to catalogue?
Well that would be kind of annoying.
So you'd want to do this stuff.
So that's one of the things we've
been thinking about, in our systems,
how do we, you know, make
things a little bit easier
by looking things up,
or choosing from lists,
or having defaults,
those kinds of things.
>> Paul: And so something long-term
that definitely the seed
could be planted in phase two,
but something we might want to look
at in the long term is maybe a way
to know that one LCSH heading
has a certain authorized list
of appropriate subdivisions.
So I'm not saying that we would
have to create an authority record,
maybe we would eventually,
but wouldn't it be great
if you could call up
that heading and see, oh,
which subdivision is appropriate?
Have a list come up, where you
could pick from that list, right?
So ways that we could sort of use
linked data, use the BIBFRAME editor
to improve on the way we can
describe resources using LCSH
when it comes to a
heading subdivision.
This is a long-term thing, and
it's one of those paradigm shifts
in the way that we approach.
Now, free-floating subdivisions
have been around for a long time,
and now I'm saying well maybe in
the future we might need to think
of another way and future
could be years, years ahead.
But the BIBFRAME pilot phase one
brought this to our attention
that hey, maybe there
is something we can do
to make this process a little
bit easier for cataloguers.
So Kirk talked a little
bit about, in a way,
that some was still a little
bit hard for me to understand,
about how he would create these
explicit lists of control terms
in id.loc.gov so the BIBFRAME
editor would look them up.
Here're some examples here.
But I wanted to ask Kirk to talk
a little bit now about the value.
You know, as we look more
towards linked data sources,
external vocabularies, internal
vocabularies, what value is there.
Is there an increasing value in
linking to an internal vocabulary?
Where you download an
external one internally
so you have a little bit
more control over it?
Or is the value more
in linking outside,
so we don't have to
duplicate the work?
And I just wanted to see
what Kirk thought about that,
from technology standpoint.
>> Kirk: I don't think it was one
of these three, but one little issue
that we kind of run into is trust.
If you-in the linked data,
you can essentially link
to other institutions'
data themselves,
so you don't necessarily
have to keep it internally.
So RDA is one example.
I mean, these lists that we have are
all on RDA's linked data service,
and we could theoretically use them.
One little issue is that
they're not exactly consumable,
at least in the past.
They're not consumable, the way that
we were doing it, in our system,
so they're a little
technologically behind.
It was still usable, but it
was just a little bit off.
Mostly because they didn't
really have a searching,
they didn't have an index,
they just have the documents.
So it's all-you almost have to cache
them, to be somewhat inefficient,
a second reason we kind
of want it internally is
because we could use our
own infrastructure to do it,
then we don't have to worry
about what happens over there.
There actually was an example
where Paul told me about a list,
I implemented it, it didn't
work because it didn't work.
It was actually the RDA
list had some errors,
and we actually had to
correct it ourselves.
And I had to tell him
about it, you know,
so we all make mistakes,
we're all new at this.
So that's one of the reasons we've
actually been like importing data
into the id.loc.gov, system.
Because that way we are in control
of it, we can make sure it works.
When someone says something
is wrong,
we have control over
it, we can fix it.
But in the future, I think we
are going to have, you know,
some things are going
to be external.
We are going to allow people in
profiles to say you know what?
There is this other
term that is useful
to my particular format
that I'm working on.
It's not an ID, but it's
from someone we trust,
and we'll go ahead and use it.
So that is one of the
things that will happen.
The same thing with our records,
I mean, one of the promises is
that we'll work on something, we'll
have a description for a resource
of some kind, and it will be there,
then people can just link to it.
They don't need to actually do copy
cataloguing, essentially, you know,
you have to go through and copy
every single piece of information
or make sure it's valid, you
can simply say you know what?
It has this number,
this URI, and it's that,
that's what we're looking for.
So we'll hopefully get
there, but we're still early,
still new at this, and
everything is up in the air.
The technology is, in some
ways, it changes so fast
that we can't keep up with it.
Other times it's like
we're inventing it
at the same time we're doing it.
Sometimes we find out we're a
little bit behind, and we get told
by other people in the community
that we need to step up our game
and stop doing something
that we thought was-some
other group had told us
that was exactly the right way
to do it [laughter], so you know,
we're all these different
directions.
So that's-I think we've
been doing a lot better,
and we have all these relationships
with other universities
that are working on the linked
data for production project,
which really is trying to kind
of work on these things where,
you know, we have things
we actually work
on to make our systems
provide resources for users.
So we need to actually make it
work, and how do we make it work?
Well we need to make
production systems.
How do we make production systems?
Well we have examples of things we
need to do, and we implement those.
So that's something we're
working on the next two years,
and I think that's something that
is going to push us a lot further,
a lot closer to really using
linked data for everything.
>> Paul: Okay so this is-we're
going to share, this is more
or less an introduction to
Sally's part of the presentation,
but we want to talk about our view
of the next steps,
based on phase one.
We want to continue to analyze
the data that Beacher mentioned,
all the descriptions are out
there, we can still look at them.
They're in vocabulary
1, but they're useful.
We want to address the
community review a BIBFRAME,
the vocabulary 2.0,
which is relatively new.
Hasn't been out that long.
Except for other control
vocabularies, you want to read any
of these or should I
just read them off?
>> Kirk: Go for it.
>> Paul: Okay, take lessons
learned from phase one [laughter]
into account as we
work on the profiles,
you know, this is our wish list.
For how can the editor be
improved for the next phase?
Refine some of the MARC mappings
that we had, and capitalize
on the positive achievements,
and there were a lot
of positive achievements.
There were some rough bumps
along the road too in phase one,
but we're capitalizing on
the positive achievements
from phase one, as we
look toward phase two.
So now, Sally McCallum will
talk about the visionary future
of what needs to be in place before
we can even contemplate starting the
next phase of the BIBFRAME pilot.
[ Applause ]
>> Sally: Thank you, and that
was an excellent introduction.
This is sort of the eight-step
program, eight-step project,
to get to the next pilot,
and it is a huge undertaking.
And the first one, the first thing
we had to do was work on the model,
and how did we want
to change the model?
How did we want to change the
vocabulary for the next pilot,
and that is 2.0, in other
words, BIBFRAME 2.0.
We had a lot of input
on 1.0 since 2014.
We've had community-wide input
on get help, we had something
like 200 comments that came
in, we reviewed all those.
On the listserv, we had
more than 200 comments.
And somebody sort of
distilled all those,
to see if there was a whole
lot of listserv comments,
can maybe yield one really pithy
comment, but still, it was important
to pick out what we could use.
We had some expert advice.
We had a consultant or two do some
work for us, and review some things,
parts of what we were doing.
We had the pilot experience.
And the things that the
additions that were made
to those profiles,
during the first pilot.
Those-what those additions
said is those are missing
in the vocabulary 1.0.
We have Program for
Cooperative Cataloguing comments.
We had the LD4P comments, and those
are-that's the cooperative project
between, among rather, Stanford,
Harvard, Cornell, Princeton,
Columbia, and the Library
of Congress.
They are funded participants,
and we are unfunded participant,
but they wanted us in their
pilot, in their program.
And they gave us a lot of comments.
And they're still giving
us comments.
We had the audiovisual media study
that we had, we commissioned,
from some audiovisual specialists
who worked with the people
at Culpeper, on it, and it gave
us a new view of an important area
that we have incorporated into 2.0,
and then we have proposal papers
for key areas, for titles,
for agents and roles,
and there were a number of these.
And we put them out and
left them out for comment,
put them out on the listserv, I'm
sorry-put them out on the website,
announced them on the listserv,
and got comments on them
for about three or four months.
So the initial model, 1.0, was
simple and innovative, we thought.
It had works, the key areas,
works, instances and annotations
for your holdings, for your
cover art, for things like that.
Very interesting idea.
And if you could see the screen,
I'm not sure you can, of the Works,
you have agents and
something else-creators.
Creators and subjects, and off
of instances, you have things
like the publication
and the typical things
that are related to
instances of works.
So our 2.0 model is fundamentally
the same, but we had a couple
of adjustments that make the
picture look a little different.
We clarified events.
And events can be content.
So they can be-the works
can have content of event.
They can also have subject of event,
and those are two different-really
different concepts
to the audiovisual
people, and so we tried
to incorporate that into the model.
We have-we added items
as a core class,
rather than calling
it-using annotations
as a substitute for item.
Now, the vocabulary.
We had a good introduction
to the fact
that what we call the
vocabulary in BIBFRAME is.
It's similar to the MARC
fields and subfields.
MARC vocabulary is 260-input
screen said probably 260.
BIBFRAME vocabulary are
single words and phrases
such as provision activity,
which is the same as a 260.
And, but on the input screen,
you can do anything you want .
And that is what Kirk and
Paul tried to make clear,
that we have more control over
what we actually use with respect
to the cataloguing environment,
and the input environment,
and we are using that control
to make it a better
environment than we had before.
Not that you didn't all
learn what a 260 and 245
and 350 and 300 and so on were.
In the vocabulary,
we also have rules.
We had to decide on.
And one-the first one was
we decided to continue
to use the resource description
framework, RDF, for the vocabulary.
MARC itself is, well,
you have a lot of tags,
which is like the vocabulary, you
also have an underlying set of rules
for how you express that, and that
is called ISO2709, it's a standard
that just gives the
platform for how you do,
how you express that vocabulary.
And we decided we would go ahead
with the W3C resource description
framework, because it is sort
of the basis for linked
data, and it is supported
by the World Wide Web Consortia,
rather than by just library groups.
You can see there are some examples
of conventions we adopted, which may
or may not mean very much, but
the distinction between data type
and object type is very
important in RDA and RDF.
You had to be able to do your label,
the text version of something.
You also wanted to be able to
have the URI at the same time,
and we had to make it
so that could happen.
And various other things that
are very...they're aspects
or characteristics of RDF.
We had to make choices on.
And so the holdings annotation
became the item core class.
Authorities in the new vocabulary
became agents and concepts.
We don't use the word authority
so much, because we use agents,
which are the persons,
organizations we use [inaudible],
and we use concepts
which are topics, places,
times, events, and works.
And then we have better
accommodation
of standardized vocabulary,
we think,
and pre-text vocabulary,
and real-world objects.
The community went very
crazy about the distinction
between real-world
object and the label
of a real-world object,
a couple of years ago.
And it's a valid distinction,
whether-and it can be
used for various things.
It's not tremendously useful, but
it can be used to make certain kinds
of inferences about things.
And so we made it a better
distinction between those two.
And most of all, we have a
better accommodation of RDA.
That vocabulary 1.0 was a
mixture of MARC and RDA.
MARC, AACR and RDA.
Whereas the new vocabulary is much
more-it's planned, it's organized,
within the RDA, organization,
like the RDA organization,
and it uses a lot of RDA.
We did finish that in April.
We published the model and the
vocabulary, and it is the foundation
of everything we do in the pilot.
So these things, these steps
come one after another,
and they are dependent
on the earlier steps.
The second one is the-the
second step is the MARC
to BIBFRAME conversion, which
is a very difficult task.
We did make a commitment in the
first pilot, and we've had one
in the second pilot, we hope to
do it better, to bring forward all
of the MARC data, so that
cataloguers, when they are trying
to create a record in BIBFRAME,
can look at the whole body
of the catalogue in BIBFRAME, and
then decide what they want to do.
And because that's the way
cataloguers have been working
and how they should work.
But there are vast
differences from MARC.
And we had to, first of all,
we had to identify
patterns in the MARC data.
But we have to deal with the
things in MARC, because MARC grew
over years, over 40 years,
and one community wanted this,
another community wanted that.
They were similar, but they
claim they were different,
so we do both of them.
Things like that have
elaborated MARC.
There is a variety of approaches,
sometimes you have statements,
sometimes you have codes,
sometimes you have control terms,
sometimes you have text.
You have all sorts
of things in MARC.
You have the extent of MARC,
which even though we were trying
to follow RDA and RDA,
the RDA model,
to some extent-we have acquisitions,
and subjects, and shelving location,
and preservation information
in MARC, that is not in RDA.
So it's not going to-RDA is not
going to tell us anything about how
to structure the vocabulary
or what we need
in the vocabulary for those areas.
We have a duplication of data, and
that is the thing, one of the things
that has proliferated over
time, is we have codes,
and this-we have the
same thing in text form.
We have the same thing maybe
in controlled vocabulary form.
We do that a lot in MARC.
We did it from the very
beginning, let me say,
but we did it increasingly
as time went on.
And we have local data.
We have a lot of important local
data in MARC that we have to record,
we have to be able to
show it to cataloguers
so that they can understand what
they're looking at from a technical,
from a cataloguing point of view.
We have to identify, we have
to have the identification
of the URIs while possible.
So we may bring a code forward,
we want to look up that code
in ID then, get a URI for it, and
substitute that URI for that code.
And as you know, we have a
lot of coded data in MARC.
Even controlled terms, we want
to take the controlled term,
we want to look it up in ID,
we want to have a URI instead
of that term, in our
RDF descriptions.
We call them descriptions when we
talk about RDF, rather than records.
Then the various RDF
techniques, we have to figure
out how we-there are several ways
you can usually do something in RDF.
We have to decide okay we're going
to do it this way, and we're going
to do it consistently this way,
rather than doing it this way
for this data, and
that way for that data,
and that way for another
kind of data.
So we want-we are trying
to keep things consistent,
and we want to eventually
make it shareable.
The conversion specs are almost
finished, and we have a consultant,
we have employed a consultant
who knows a lot about MARC,
and a lot about linked data,
who is going to do the-write the
actual programs for the conversion.
Step three, MARC to BIBFRAME
conversion program, we create,
we need to create the
conversions of the test programs.
We need to create a conversion
service for the community
for experimentation if possible.
And that actually seems like a
little extra that we shouldn't have
to do, but it is very useful
and we found it very useful
with the 1.0 vocabulary, because the
people in the community got right
on it, converted records that took
this converter, convert records,
and try to give us feedback.
And that is more than,
you know, we can get even
from our own cataloguers.
We got it from across the country.
So it's very, very important.
And we want to share those
programs that, we always do share,
and we always try to share.
Step four, preparation of the files.
We have to take the-and this is
a big, this is a huge project,
part of the project, we have to
take the MARC title authorities,
and they become BIBFRAME works.
Work descriptions.
We have to take the bib
records with uniform titles,
match them with these work
records, and merge them
into the work description.
So we have these match and
merge, match and merge.
We have MARC records with uniform
titles, but no authority record,
which there are many of those.
And we have to create a work.
So we have to distinguish between
those that have uniform titles,
and no authority, and those
that have uniform titles
and do have an authority, so that we
can create a BIBFRAME work record.
We have to take MARC bib records
that are without uniform titles,
and there, we can create a
BIBFRAME work description.
Then we have to merge the
subjects from the BIBFRAME,
from the MARC records, into
the BIBFRAME work descriptions,
and consolidate the subjects.
If there is more than
one MARC record that goes
to one BIBFRAME work record, we
have to take the subjects from both
of them, merge those in some
way, and put them together,
and put them on the work record.
And then the MARC bibs, we
finally-what's left, we have to go,
after we've taken all
the work information off,
we have to split the instances.
And that is very difficult, because
of the way we've done that in MARC
over time, and that we tried to sort
of push in different instance types
into one record, because
it helped with our systems.
Our systems worked that way.
And so we do have-we want
to try to split those off,
then, in the new environment.
Which is, again, that's RDA, and
the way RDA would like for it
to see a structure and model
bibliographic data for, they think,
a better user experience.
And while we're doing this, we want
to keep pointers among the new work
and instance records
and descriptions
so that these things don't fragment.
Step five.
We've got to prepare the-we've
had to prepare the infrastructure,
and that's been ongoing
since, oh, last year actually.
We use the-and this is the hard core
platform, this is what Nate Trail,
in our office, is a person
who handles this the most.
That's his focus, let's say.
The LC uses the MARC
object platform.
We've had a major move
of the platform internally
to virtual servers.
Now, we have accomplished
that with difficulty,
but with very good
assistance from OCIO,
from the newly reorganized OCIO.
We have had a major version upgrade
of the platform, with the addition
of a new semantic module.
We have done that.
We've got that in place, but we have
not got all the data loaded to it.
Because we need to have lots less
movement, then, of all the data
that we have in the old version,
and the old linked data service
into the new linked data
service, without interruption.
And this is not-I mean,
while the pilot uses ID,
the linked data service,
the community uses it a lot.
There are peak times when there
are several million hits a day
on that service, and other
times when it's more like two
or three hundred thousand.
But it's always very intensely used.
People have gotten-they-the linked
data service has been in operation
for one vocabulary, then
two, and three, four, five,
for the last six years,
because it came up in 2010.
And so a lot of people,
a lot of systems people
out there have started using
it to update their systems,
to get information, to get
current information from us.
So we-and when it goes down,
they let us know [laughter].
So we have to do that without
interruption, and then we have
to plan and load the new, revise
the re-converted BIBFRAME files,
in this new semantic environment.
And we had a different kind of
semantic environment before.
Step six, we have to
revise the BIBFRAME editor
and the BIBFRAME profile editor.
And you've heard a lot
about that this morning,
more than what I would
be ready to say,
review and revise editor
functionality,
and revise the interface labels.
I think they told you,
Paul, I think,
told you about how the labels
were designed for the interface,
and he has, I'm sure,
ideas on how he wants
to redesign or revise those labels.
Based on what his interactions
with the cataloguers,
in the pilot-we have a lot to do,
and we have to make this
available to the community.
We have to rebuild the
links between the editor
and the actual vocabulary.
Step seven, review and augment
the linked data service.
It's an integral part of the pilot,
so we want the editor-it provides
the editor with its drop downs,
with its look ahead information,
with all sorts of things,
and while I've talked earlier
about the outward use of it,
it's also a very heavy
inward use of it,
for the BIBFRAME, and for the pilot.
It provides the URIs for the data,
during our preparation stage,
when we're preparing the files.
We need to redesign
this application,
move it to MarkLogic,
and augment it.
And finally, step eight.
A very big one.
It was excellently done for the
first pilot, and that's the work
that COIN does for preparing the
materials, training material,
holding retraining sessions,
holding new training sessions.
They had an excellent-did
an excellent job of setting
up feedback mechanisms, so that-and
giving cataloguers constant support,
so that I think it was every
week or every couple of weeks,
they had a session that you can
come if you're having trouble, come,
if you don't have trouble, you can
just continue to work that day.
So they did a lot of work
to prepare the documentation
and to hold training,
and to hold the hands
of the people during the pilot.
So part of-we're starting a
wish list for the new pilot.
I think a few, Kirk and Paul,
made a few comments on that.
We would like to have daily
conversion of the BIBFRAME,
to BIBFRAME, and load of
the new bib descriptions,
with the first pilot we could not
have daily load of bib records.
We had daily load of authority
records that were coming
into the ILS, and then coming into
BIBFRAME, but not bib records.
There is a major undertaking, major
challenge, to be able to do that.
Because you've got to
do this merge and match
when you bring any one
record into this set
of records that is already there.
And we would like to have an input
editor for names, and for subjects,
so that people could have an
experience of what it's like to try
to do their names, and their
subjects, authorities essentially.
I've used that word,
but I'm not supposed to.
But at any rate, those descriptions,
in the right-in the environment
they're doing their Bib record in.
So take away from this, what I
said, Keystone is the vocabulary.
We're having some trouble with that,
but if the vocabulary
keeps changing,
then we have to keep changing
all these things, all the way up,
including the documentation
for the training.
And all other caches are dependent
on it, therefore on its stability.
But we see the pilots as essential
for understanding what we're going
into for the migration of
MARC to the new platform,
which we've done a lot of work
trying to make that as good
as possible, because we have 50,
100 years of cataloging information
that we can't lose and we must
be able to bring it forward.
And it also, we see this
as part of understanding,
how we make libraries a part
of the linked data environment.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Beacher: Now we are open for
questions to any and all of us.
We'll just start [inaudible].
>> Is the intention to be able
to save the records this time,
so that it can be used
to [inaudible] be there,
like in the first pilot,
and not be able [inaudible]?
>> Well all need to stand up?
>> Yes.
>> Well someone who
is going to answer.
>> I think a better thing
to think of, actually,
is that the editor was just
an input screen initially.
It doesn't do anything.
And so is that useful
for production?
Well no. Because you need to do
things like you're mentioning.
So then what do you need for that?
You need a bunch of things behind
the scenes, to make it all work.
And so that's what
Sally was talking about.
It's part of getting all the
stuff behind the scenes working.
We're going to have whatever
the editor is called in 2.0,
I'm leaning toward renaming
it something completely,
because it's going to be really a
part of a prototype ILS like system,
rather than just simply an editor
where you can just
type things in fields.
So it will have saving, and we're
really hopeful we'll have a lot more
features, not just
entering descriptions.
Like Paul said, we've
always had this hope
that you can do a lot more
things, like authority work.
And so that's another thing
I think we don't want to do.
So you could actually go into
an ID record, for a name,
actually open it up, and maybe make
a change to it and save it back
into ID, into our system.
I think that's one thing we'd also
like to do, because I think that's,
and then that would somehow flow
into the Voyager system, somehow.
I mean that would be
like years in the future,
we might actually do that.
But that's one of the ideas.
>> Jada?
>> Beacher: I'm supposed to come up
here because we are being filmed.
Regina? [Laughter]
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Given that RDA can
be output as RDF,
given that there were
[inaudible] and company,
have developed [inaudible], a demo
editor for outputting RDA as RDF,
or they say as [inaudible].
What-why isn't or is
LC investigating going
in those directions as opposed
to working on its own to sort
of parallel some of these efforts?
>> Beacher: Well I don't-I think
as several of us have said,
we are collaborating and
working with various constituents
in the community, and
we are, and have been,
working with Deborah Fritz, and
company, and I'm on the RDA Board,
and the RDA Board has, I think it's
fair to say, adopted [inaudible]
as one of the paths
it wants to take.
I know Paul and Judith in particular
have worked with Deborah and several
of the ALA Meetings, to see
how these come together,
and it was also part
of what we discussed
at the OpCo meeting in May.
Paul or Judith, do you have
further elaboration on that?
Or even Sally or Kirk,
beyond the fact
that we are taking
those into account?
>> I think it's a good question.
It's a valid question.
But from my perspective, we're still
so new at this, that there needs
to be a lot of experimentation still
among different constituents before
we all come together
and agree on something.
We have used Deborah's
product, the RIMMF,
and I think we had a very
productive demonstration of how
that could be used to
display visualize RDA,
and then we use the BIBFRAME editor.
That's the type of experimentation
that I still think needs
to take place before we
actually, you know, buckle down
and say this is the
way we're going to go.
>> One of the things that I
think LD4P is really focusing
on is partnering with each
other, working with each other
on strengths and weaknesses.
The RIMMF editor is as far as
I know a Visual BASIC doc type
which is not very popular
in the library community.
It's closed source.
It's not open source.
These are about open source.
It's the opposite, where it's
not accessible by anyone,
certainly you could use it,
like they have a license,
where you can actually use the tool,
but you can't make any changes
to it, as far as I know.
And so it becomes kind of
difficult while it's a great-I mean,
it's been great for the
community, and people like it,
but how can I integrate it
into our MarkLogic system?
Well, it's not possible,
because it's in Visual BASIC,
and that's not one of the options.
And so certainly we could
port it to something else,
but that would be a really large
effort to do that, and you know,
essentially that's what we're doing.
So I am kind of disappointed
that's one of the cases
with that particular tool,
that it seems like we don't
really have them, you know,
we don't have that in our
development community where,
as far as I know, none of the
LD4P partners are thinking
about RIMMF for, you know, porting
it or working with them at all.
So that makes it difficult.
As far as the vocabulary, I know
one thing that has come up before,
and I think conversations, Sally
might hopefully be able to agree
with me is that people
consider RDA's version
of RDF is too complicated.
It's like-there's obviously a
need for complicated vocabularies,
because the world is complex.
So you need to have things.
But at the same time, if you look on
Google, what happens on the screen?
Well, you know, you get a list
of gobbledy goop, you know,
it's just a bunch of words.
And certainly it seems behind
the scenes it does all sorts
of great things with their
keyword searches, but it's really,
actually relatively simple, like
the amount of stuff they have.
And one that they've, you know,
ontology really prefer is,
is [inaudible] which is a
lot flatter than BIBFRAME.
It doesn't have a lot of classes,
but has lots of properties.
And even those properties,
there's lots of possibilities,
but I think we were investigating
some of the implementations of that
for library materials, and it
was like 8 or 10 properties.
So it's pretty simple.
If you look at something like, you
know Dublin core is used by DPLA,
and Europeana, they have
about 20, 21 properties.
I think I was telling Sally
about that the other day.
So they're-they've dealt
with the complexity
by making it less complex,
but because of that,
it doesn't accept the range
of descriptions that a lot
of times different
library communities want
because they really do want to be
able to describe things in a lot
of detail, and it could
be difficult to do
that if you only have
21 property options.
Of which about five or six I
think are just for the system.
So. You know, that's one of the
things I think is a challenge.
It's that is Google
going to adopt RDA?
I don't think they even understand
it or know about it [laughter],
and so, I know that's something
I worry about with BIBFRAME.
Because BIBFRAME is still
complex, but I think we
at least-our goal is to-we
want to be able to hook
into these other things that
are maybe not as complex,
but we have some, you know,
we're thinking about same
as relationships, where you
can say it's the same as.
So if you're searching in
one of those ontologies,
at least you can get some BIBFRAME,
and maybe as they get more BIBFRAME,
it becomes more useful
and they see it's there.
And if we have a big volume of it,
it's going to be useful to Google,
and they're going to use some of
it, so that's one of the goals.
So it's a challenge.
I mean, not everything
works in technology.
Maybe people succeed.
Maybe RDA is better
than what, I mean,
we're all doing experimentation.
We are not quite there, but that's
one of the things I think about.
So, good question.
>> That's very helpful.
>> Aaron?
>> How is it with let's
say, distinguishing
between let's say baseball,
in Australia, with Cricket,
in the United States, you
know, the [inaudible]?
Keyword searching, you don't have
the link between the subfield D
and the subfield A, you would not
be able to distinguish that record
from baseball in the
United States with cricket
in Australia, but [inaudible] works.
The examples you show for subjects
don't seem to have the ability
to break down fields,
eliminate subfields.
Is there a commitment to preserve
the pre-coordination [inaudible]?
I know RDA seems to be wanting
to make sure [inaudible]
will accommodate RDA.
Is there a similar commitment
to preserve LCSH and BIBFRAME?
>> Well, definitely during phase
one, and most likely phase two,
as I said, cataloguers had to do
everything that they do now in MARC,
in BIBFRAME, and the Library of
Congress has made a commitment
to continue to pre-coordinate
LCSH strings,
so that's why we were doing that.
The point I was trying to
make is that what happens
when that pre-coordinated string
is not matched by something
that can retrieve it
again sometimes?
So yes, we definitely are continuing
LCSH as we're instructed to do now
in BIBFRAME, and I know that will
continue into the next pilot.
>> Beacher: Peter?
>> Peter: I have a question about,
okay, is the editor going to come
in a new ILS, for instance,
[inaudible]?
Because I know that [inaudible] will
no longer be supported [inaudible]-
>> That's not true.
>> Oh it's not?
Oh, okay [laughter], so I'm
still questioning what is coming
for the next generation of
ILS's and different it is.
>> Well, I'm probably the
last person who should answer
that question, but I will say,
I'll confirm what Anne said,
Voyager is supported, and right
now, we're not looking at BIBFRAME
as a database of entry, I mean,
that's coming down the road.
Maybe you all could add
some comments to that?
>> Beacher: No, I think that's
not one that we will answer,
and Anne said it succinctly,
she has responsibility for that,
and she will be keeping all
of us apprised of her...foray
into replacement system for
Voyager, but now Voyager is Voyager,
and BIBFRAME, we will overlay
on the system that we have.
Questions in the back?
Since I have been starting
at the front?
Any remaining questions?
If not, I know Judith has a
statement she wants to make,
Sally is there anything
else you need to say?
And my other colleagues?
Okay. Judith?
>> Judith: I just want
you all to know
that I have Beacher's permission
to put on a series of sessions,
probably in the dining room,
I will find out when I
can get the dining rooms,
and they will be an opportunity for
people that were not in the pilot
to have a closer look at the editor.
It won't be hands on.
I'll be calling on Les, and
Hien and Tim, and Manon,
to provide this training.
But I am curious, how many
of you would be interested
in taking a closer look at the
editor, and what people that are
in the pilot are seeing and doing?
Because I know today it
was very difficult for you
to see the screens, but
there wasn't much we could do
because it was being filmed,
and they need the light.
So is it-what's the
level of interest?
Oh good, well I'll start
with a couple of sessions.
If I need more, I'll put on more.
They'll probably last
a couple of hours,
but it will give you an opportunity
to have a really good look
at the editor, and see how
it's filled in by those
that are working on the pilot.
And when we finish phase 2,
I'll do the same for you,
so that you can all keep current.
Alright. Yes?
>> Could you be sure to include
Culpeper in that initiative?
>> Okie dokey, we'll
do that [laughter].
Yes. Sorry.
>> Beacher: You can tell by
her face, you'll have to figure
out how she's going
to do that [laughter].
>> Yes?
>> I have a question
for, uh, Kirk and Paul.
Did I get the name right?
>> Yeah.
>> And this must have been
with the authority creation,
you said that there is a delay with
using the different editor in order
to get a name that had
not been established,
then you can establish it,
and then it gets uploaded.
But in the future, we're always
going to be referring to ID
for doing all of our
creation of authority work,
will there always be that delay?
Is there some way to
make it more seamless?
Is that something you're
thinking about?
Is that something that has come up?
>> Kirk: Judith told me I
have to repeat the question.
I know the answer, but I'm trying
to think of what the question was.
So that basically [laughter], you
have to basically think about,
you know, obviously we're doing
things in MARC or Voyager,
then we're porting it over to
ID, and then there is a delay,
because it takes a day or something,
whereas we could just simply
enter it in ID and be there.
And then it would go to Voyager,
and probably could also be
a little bit more seamless.
So yeah, I mean, I think
that's definitely one
of the things you want
to do because, you know,
especially with names,
I think that's one
of the things we really could
accomplish, but you know,
it takes some more effort
because it's kind of-uh, again,
I might be overstepping my
bounds, but I feel like it's kind
of stepping from experimental to
production, when we're you know,
I don't want to get yelled at, about
stepping into Voyager's domain,
but basically that's
what would happen.
We'd have to really push it into
their court, as something else,
and that's another thing
they'd have to work on
and maybe they're not staffed
for that right now, so you know,
but we've got to-I think that's
one of the things we have to think
about as part of this pilot.
It is that once we experiment with
names, maybe we can, you know,
in one of our test databases,
we could actually enter things
immediately and then figure out how
to generate, you know, MARC,
basically at the same time
at that point, as maybe we
can change our processes.
So it's a little bit more efficient.
And I think we can do more
with our linked data service
than we can with the MARC authority.
So maybe there are actually some
enhancements we can put there,
to make it a little
bit easier to use.
So there is a lot of promise there.
That's one of the things I hope
we get a lot of good information
when we work on that,
our next pilot.
>> Beacher: Paul, did
you want to comment?
>> Paul: Well, I can't
resist the opportunity.
Okay, so when Aaron asked his
question, I had to say that,
you know, we're making, we're saying
that cataloguers should not have
to do anything differently.
So I'm just going to say something.
Think of a future, possibly
where maybe you don't use just
the name authority file from LC,
maybe you link to another
authority file?
And then in another country,
another-something like that.
That's what linked
data is all about.
So that's where we're
thinking ahead,
where we might-where there
might be possibilities
to change the way we do things now,
so I just had to put that out there.
>> Beacher: Mira?
>> Mira: I just wanted to know
when do you anticipate
the next phase to begin?
>> Beacher: Yes, that's what
I was going to wrap up with.
I was amazed no one had
[laughter] raised that yet.
As you heard from me earlier
in giving you the recap,
I'm always pressing to go
faster, faster, more and more.
My colleagues, and I think
Sally laid out a very strong
and clear path to getting
to the next pilot.
I wanted to start in the first
quarter of the new fiscal year.
I think based on what you
heard today, it's fair to say,
we will not have the next pilot
begin before January 2017.
I want the technical side to
have the time to do the things
that they need to do, so that
the next pilot is not as rushed
and frantic as the first one,
and that there is more confidence
in the stability of
both the vocabulary
and the infrastructure
that will support that.
So as of today, I think it's
fair to say that we're aiming
for the second quarter of fiscal
2017, meaning not before January.
In the interim, then, we'll
be having these sessions
as we are having, similar to today,
and the ones that Judith just
described in terms of giving those
of you who are not
necessarily involved
in the pilot now a better
sense of what the tool is like,
and what is involved in
getting ready for the pilot.
Do I have any objections
from my colleagues
on the front row [laughter],
alright.
They set the stage for
this at ALA Annual,
when I had been saying the first
quarter, then by the time I got
up to make a presentation, I had to
say, well, I'm being pushed back,
and I think this really does make
sense in terms of the complexity
of what we want to do, and
that this is really going
to be a transformative
initiative, not just for our area,
but for the Library of Congress
itself, and the community
with which we are working.
On that note, are there any final
questions or points to be raised?
We have about three minutes.
If not, then we will close
with that, and I thank you
for your participation
and my colleagues
for the work they're
doing [applause begins]
to make this happen
[applause continues].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.